[Rollo yells]
Tyr Neilsen: Rollo's
using a Viking battle-ax.
You can turn, you can pull,
and if it's used against
an opponent's legs,
it can be pulled up.
There's lots and lots of tricks.
Hi, my name is Tyr Neilsen.
I'm president of the
Norwegian Glima Federation
and a senior instructor
at the Academy of Viking
Martial Arts in Norway.
Today, we're going to be looking
at ax-fight scenes in movies and TV.
There's different ways to
hold a weapon in single hand.
When you have two weapons,
there's a different thought process.
In this situation,
I would use the ax with my lead hand,
and maybe I would reverse
grip with another weapon.
If I preferred to use the knife,
then I would hold the
knife in my preferred hand
and try and cut as much
as I could with the ax.
I'd follow up with the knife,
either in a forward
grip or a reverse grip,
dual wielding.
Vikings, according to the
sagas, used two weapons.
Sometimes they hid the
ax behind the shield.
So, as you grip the shield here,
you can hold the ax and
the shield handle here,
so it wouldn't be seen by the opponent.
And if you drop your shield
or if it gets destroyed,
you quickly have another
weapon in your hand.
This is very realistic choreography.
He's using basic strikes.
No sneaky techniques
and no small, direct cuts.
He's swinging with that intention.
One of them could work.
He only needs to connect
with the guy's arm or wrist or fingers
before you've created serious damage.
The way they engage is
similar to glima techniques.
You try and trap the hand
that's being used against you.
If it has a weapon, you try and trap
the weapon or the arm,
and you use that to control
the balance of the opponent.
Lots of different styles
do similar things,
and my father-in-law
began to teach me glima techniques,
which are based on the
battlefield wrestling
from the Viking age.
These are passed down quite secretly,
because Norway has been
ruled by other nations
and occupied by Germany
in the second world war,
so their means of fighting hands-on combat
were held pretty close to the chest.
It goes into grappling, and
the grappling was great.
It was quite brutal,
and I really enjoyed it.
Seven out of 10.
It was a very tense and
quite realistic ax fight.
You want to control your
opponent's weapon if possible,
and by grabbing your opponent's weapon,
especially near the ax head,
you can use it against the opponent.
This is my favorite Viking ax.
The toe edge would have been
a couple of centimeters higher
and then come to a lethal point,
and the heel would have
also come down to a point,
which would have been also lethal.
And it would have been very, very sharp.
This is a typical Viking ax.
And then this is what
they call the bearded ax,
because this part of the ax,
they call the beard.
And it has an elongated beard,
and you can grip it here
and use it to shave or cut.
And it can be deadly when
you move into this grip.
When you close up properly,
you can use it as a knife
when in close combat.
There are many decorated Viking axes.
Vikings like to decorate
pretty much everything.
On the haft, they would be protected
with leather, nails, or wrapped in metal,
and there's some examples from the sagas.
This would protect the
wooden haft from any attack.
Not always, because it's
wood. It would split.
But it helps.
It would be great if the producers
got in contact with people
who fight in the style
that the people in the show
were going to be fighting in,
because there's a lot of
information and techniques there.
You can use that as a platform
to make better choreography.
This was very exciting, quite realistic,
and a great starter for the whole show.
Rollo's using a Viking battle-ax,
which is an incredibly dangerous weapon.
The ax head goes through the shield.
It can be a dangerous move.
If the ax head gets stuck in the shield,
it can be used against you.
I have a Viking battle-ax,
also called a Dane ax.
And if you imagine my arm is a shield,
you can hook over the top of
the shield and pull it down,
and you can do it really quickly.
This is just a small ax head.
You can turn, you can pull,
and if it's used against
an opponent's legs,
it can be pulled up.
You can push forward
to open up the shield.
There's lots and lots of tricks with this.
And you can use the ax as a stick.
You can use either this end or this end,
or you can use it as a stick
weapon here and then turn.
It's made to be maneuvered around.
If you start here, you
can deceive a little
and then send it out quite a long way.
He uses it with technique, strength.
Seven out of 10.
I believe Rollo, and, the
character from the show,
I really wouldn't want
to meet him in a fight.
Viking boys, growing up,
they get bored, as kids do,
and they would start wrestling,
fighting with weapons.
Every one of them was quite good
at throwing axes, throwing knives.
When we're doing seminars,
we're not instructing
and we're hanging around,
people throw their weapons,
they throw their axes,
they throw their knives.
It's a very natural thing to do.
I could throw the ax with
pretty good accuracy.
I don't know if I would
cut the ropes first time,
but I would imagine that
that character could and would.
And as he did,
10 out of 10, because he cut the ropes.
I don't know anybody who
would swing a two-bladed
or two-bit ax around their body like this.
It would be too easy to
cut off your own limb.
It could get caught in material.
It could rebound. It could be deflected.
There's lots of things that
can happen unexpectedly.
I don't know the weight of the weapon,
I don't know what type of
material it's made out of,
but if you're living 6,000 years,
you've had a lot of practice.
You're pretty much invulnerable.
You could do this. If you're showing off,
if you're building up the
energy, the determination,
might happen, but I wouldn't recommend it.
And I think that this
is based on the labrys,
which is a ancient weapon
from Crete, Greece.
It was more of a ceremonial weapon
than anything that they
would use in battle.
There's a lot of discourse about
the pros and cons of this
and what it was used for.
In a sacred ceremony,
it might've been used
to sacrifice an animal, for example.
The choreography is interesting.
Because she didn't cut off any limbs,
she gets 10 out of 10.
[laughing]
Hm.
Well, I don't think anybody ever
wants to be put in the position
where they have to
criticize a John Wick movie.
It looks like they're
using a woodsman's ax
or something about this size.
It weighs between 1 1/2, 2 pounds,
it's really easy to swing around,
and it's very lethal,
especially in short distances
and in a compact room, the way this is.
I doubt that they're sharp.
If we believe the scene,
this is an incredibly scary situation.
He's doing really good techniques,
blocking, powering, moving
out of the way. I love it.
You have to trap and lock it away.
You have to make sure that
you're not at the distance
where you can easily be cut by it.
Maybe get inside the weapon.
In glima, there's an
awful lot of techniques
we use to intercept, to trap, to hold,
to maneuver the opponent's body weight
in such a way that they
don't have the best stability
so that they can use the weapon.
I really can't find a fault
or say if you did this it would be better,
so 10 out of 10.
He's using a long-hafted ax.
He's going to have to do something
to change the disadvantage of his height
into an advantage,
and this is a really good way of doing it.
He can reach up high because
he's using that weapon.
I would suggest that he
cuts more ankles and legs,
because that's easier.
And if your opponent can't walk,
then they can't run
after you or attack you.
The way he's using the ax is
an extension of his character,
and he's trying to kill with every blow.
He wants to show that he's powerful
with every single stroke.
The problem with swinging
heavily every time
is that you drain your
energy, which is limited.
You open yourself up if you bring it back
in order to swing it forward.
So, this is a regular modern tomahawk ax.
And instead of it being
brought all the way back
in order to go forward,
that would be a move.
And this is quite sharp.
The tips are quite sharp.
It's heavy enough.
It's got this at the end,
and that would be doing quite
a lot of damage from here.
And you don't really need
to do much more than that,
if you understand what you're attacking.
And when you chuck it....
And the way he uses it, seven out of 10.
Chris Evans sells this so well.
He's a good actor who can sell action.
He changes hands,
he goes from single grip to double grip,
he has good turns and good angles,
he changes levels.
A good fighter will try and create
as much space around them as possible.
Try and use opponents' shields,
move around them in a way that
they shield or block for you.
The most difficult thing of
all is to keep your balance.
And then he does what he should do,
which is attack the legs
and try and get out of
there as soon as possible.
We don't play any defensive
game on the ground.
We don't fall; we're taught to land.
And so no matter what
happens, as you're going down,
you're going down with the intention
to land in a way that will enable you
to move out of danger
as quickly as possible.
Nine out of 10.
If somebody has that much confidence
and swings it around in such a
way that it doesn't look like
they're going to injure themselves at all
and you do not know where the
attack is going to come from,
what happens is it's hard
to see the angle of attack.
Whichever way they begin the movement,
there's many, many tells, from the neck,
the shoulder, the bicep,
the tricep, the elbow.
There's lots and lots of tells.
The way they move their feet,
the way they move their head.
But when that weapon is already in motion,
you can't just attack or
defend against that angle,
because it can suddenly change.
It's intimidating.
Where you place your feet,
when I look at technique,
you can see what's happening
just from the footwork.
Footwork is a major
part of any martial art.
It's often neglected
because it's not as exciting
as twirling your weapon
around in your hand,
but being able to move at angles,
move forward, move backwards,
move as you change your height,
it's so, so important. It's core.
Balance is everything.
They use their weapon to
hook the opponent's weapon
and control the opponent's weapon
and the opponent's balance.
If I can just show it here,
the opponent's weapon,
you go over the top,
you can either pull and go forward
or just go over the top and go forward.
You don't need these big movements.
So, over the weapon,
force it in a direction away from you,
and that's all you need.
I felt it was really well done
and it was scary and good technique.
Eight out of 10.
He leaves himself open
because he is full of bravado,
but it works really well
because even though he opens himself up,
he knows exactly what to do
to close it up again and attacking you.
In this scene, Ajax cuts through
a good chunk of metal with his ax.
It could happen, maybe. I haven't tried.
These are dangerous weapons,
and they can cut through quite a lot.
I think this is based on a fireman's ax.
I've never seen one which
is completely metal.
There's different rhythms in a fight,
and you can change rhythm in a fight.
Instead of getting dragged
into a readable rhythm,
you can break the rhythm.
And then you change the
dynamic of the fight
by changing the speed of
one weapon against another
and getting them in
unison or working apart.
A delayed swing changes everything.
I'd give this nine out of 10.
I really enjoyed it.
I've watched this with my son many times.
We really enjoy this scene.
The way he moves is impressive.
If your opponent can move quickly,
if they know how to use a weapon,
that's a game changer.
The fact that you can
use an anonymous object
as a weapon or as a counter
to these weapons is smart.
Maybe going in and
smothering your opponent
and trying to strip their
weapon away would work.
But you also have a second attacker
coming in with another ax.
There's no sure way that
you come out of this alive,
but as a scene, it's inventive.
We do train against multiple attackers
and multiple attackers with weapons.
One of the basic principles
that you have to understand
is that you want to be able
to control your opponents
and use that opponent to
control a second opponent.
Use them as a shield,
use their weapon as a
counterweapon or as a shield.
I'd like to give this 10 out of 10.
I just thoroughly enjoyed it.
It is always enjoyable
to see somebody move
the way she moves in this scene.
I think this was one long take.
She's elegant. She's determined.
And when you're using weapons,
they should be an extension of your body,
and this scene really
shows that part of a fight.
I wouldn't recommend
anyone fighting this way,
but if you're a person
with these capabilities
and this is your style,
then you can make it work for you.
I would not do this.
The style that I train and teach
is about making the best decisions
in the shortest possible time.
I think she's using a fantasy weapon.
I don't know what it's based on,
but the Vikings had a similar type of ax
where there's a long beard,
which is used for carving or cutting.
If it has a long tang,
which means that the
metal from the ax head
goes all the way through the handle,
then it could be really
well balanced, light, sharp.
Nine out of 10.
Thor's weapon, Stormbreaker,
could be based on a Viking battle-ax,
but it looks more like a poleax.
You have bladed end of the head
and a hammer-type impact
tool on the opposite end
on the top of a long pole at its core.
It's believable.
It's just gone into fantasy territory,
but it's used the same way.
There's many, many strange
weapons from history.
Not every ax, haft, or
handle was straight.
There's lots of curves,
and some of them really long curves.
Sometimes they used
the roots of a wood,
the natural curve, so that
that curve was strong.
So, the opponent's weapon
is being used against him.
That's a really good thing to understand,
that it's not something
you just want to get out of the way of,
but you can turn it on your opponent,
and they show this really well here.
Maybe closer to the ax
head in this instance.
Use force, maneuverability,
balance, technique, whatever you can
to try and change the
disadvantage into an advantage.
There's not a lot of
impressive technique here,
but the core basics are there,
so five out of 10.
Even in a street fight,
people can get caught up in thinking
that this is a contest of strength,
and they both push against each other.
People can freeze. There's
lots of things that can happen.